what's up everyone welcome to the video
today we're going to take a look at how
to program a remote key fob to a Chevy
Silverado
so in order to do this we'll need an
ignition key for the vehicle
and all the remotes that you want to
work for it that's going to include any
that already already are programmed as
they'll need to be reprogrammed in
during the procedure so here I have my
new unprogrammed key
and here I have my working one
see that one works
this one doesn't
so what we want to do is take our key
put it in the ignition now we're going
to press and hold down the unlock button
on the driver's door and continue to
hold it down so press and keep holding
it down
I'm going to come over to the ignition
I'm going to turn the ignition from on
to off two times and you need to do this
pretty quickly one
two release the unlock button the door
lock cycle there indicating the vehicle
is now in programming mode
so we'll grab the new remote and we're
going to hold down both the lock and
unlock button at the same time and
continue to hold those both down until
the door lock cycle again
and sometimes this can take up to 15 or
20 seconds
door lock cycled indicating this remotes
now programmed
now we'll grab this one same thing press
and hold down the lock and unlock button
continue to hold them down until the
door lock cycle again
this remote's not successfully
programmed at this point if you have any
additional remotes you'll repeat that
previous step for each remote pressing
and holding down the unlock button until
the door lock cycle
once you're done adding remotes you can
turn the ignition to the on
position to exit programming mode
and now let's take the key out and test
the remotes
so this was our original remote
that one works
and here's the new one
that one works as well
if you have any questions please let me
know if you could take a second to like
And subscribe it helps us out and I'd
appreciate it
thank you